hi there steve here again to talk about
language learning
and today i'm going to talk about
sort of
the strategy
what is the strategy
that you need to have to learn another
language
this is something that i've gradually
gotten used to
um when i was 20 when i um had just
finished learning french and was about
to learn chinese
you know i never thought that at the age
of 72
i would be trying to learn arabic and
farsi and that these would be my
whatever it is 16 17 18 languages i
never would have thought that was
possible
i have gotten used to the idea
that i can learn any language i want
what's more i've come to realize that
i learn by not learning or by not
studying in other words the process is
one of getting used to another language
developing habits in another language in
the previous video i spoke about
you know the subjunctive and that it's
not a matter of understanding the theory
of when we use the subjunctive although
that is certainly part of what we do but
we can't remember those
explanations those rules we can't
remember the different endings
but with enough exposure to the language
we start to get used to these patterns
of the other language
so i noticed myself for example when i
see the meaning of a word so i'm
learning on link and i look up a word
and there's a dictionary definition
there
which may or may not be suitable to my
context because very often the
dictionary definition doesn't work or
maybe the word was misspelled or any
number of things could
you know give me an answer
a meaning for that word that doesn't
suit
it never bothers me
because i know from experience
that until i see that word in many
different situations
until i get used to that word i really
won't know how to use it and i i really
won't know its meaning or the scope of
its meaning and which words it's used
together with
so it's not a matter of learning stuff
studying stuff it in isolation it's it's
a matter of giving yourself enough
opportunity so that the brain can start
to get used to
a different approach so
right now with my farsi i'm listening to
it i'm getting a better sense of the
sounds i think i can clearly tell when
one word ends and the next word begins
i've got a few words
the system tells me i know 50 words or
something
uh very early in the game but i just
know that with enough time with enough
reading and listening i will get used to
farsi just as i got used to greek and
ukrainian and now in my arabic for
example
um we have this wonderful version of who
is she that was created for me by
someone that i found on upwork
and i i listened to it i understand it
and it's it's music to my ears it's so
pleasantly uh narrated
and i know that even if i keep
forgetting words that this is just part
of this process of getting used to
another language developing new habits
and we develop these new habits
you know
subconsciously in a way and and i am
very confident now
that
with enough exposure with enough reading
and listening i will get used to
another language i can get used to any
language turkish finnish mongolian
swahili it doesn't matter
now
again you know some people maybe think
older people can't learn languages
when i was 20 i didn't have that
attitude i didn't have the attitude that
i can simply
learn any language as long as i give my
brain the opportunity
by enough exposure
you know give my brain the opportunity
to get used to a new language to develop
new neural connections to deal with a
new language as long as i do that and as
long as i want to get this language in
me i can do it any language and this is
the way i feel now it's certainly not
how i felt when i was in my teens when
it seemed like
learning a new language was very
difficult i was confronted with you know
conjunction at least conjugation tables
declension tables rules and it just
seemed like a real struggle whereas i
now realize that it's a very gradual
process
of getting used to something so the
strategy in language learning should be
to ignore tests
to not worry about what you forget not
worry about what you understand you know
understand or don't understand and just
focus on letting yourself get used to
the new language so that's the strategy
i hope this makes sense bye for now
[Music]
you